faut-il crème monsieur le général une
troisième guerre mondiale il faut
craindre une troisième guerre mondiale
nous n'y sommes pas mais nous pourrions
basculer dans cette guerre ce qui est
sûr c'est que nous sommes dans la plus
grave crise de l'europe depuis la fin de
la deuxième guerre mondiale et nous
sommes dans une situation très
particulière puisque nous sommes
peut-être
à la veille d'un affrontement entre deux
puissances dotées d'armes nucléaires et
ça peut basculer et c'est pour ça que
nos dirigeants en particulier dirigeants
occidentaux doivent faire preuve du plus
grand sang froid de la plus grande
clairvoyance pour arriver à sortir de ce
conflit sans que justement nous ne
basculons dans une guerre mondiale qui
compte tenu du fait qu'elle serait
nucléaire aurait des conséquences
absolument dramatiques sur la terre
entière qu'est ce que vous diriez de la
personnalité de vladimir poutine quand
vous analysez à la fois ci réaction et
la stratégie qu'il a adoptée est ce que
la niant poutine était incontrôlable
selon vous où on est encore dans une
forme de rationalité avec un dialogue
impossible
monsieur poutine à une rationalité et
elle n'est pas la nôtre il n'est pas de
notre monde il a il est en train de
conduire c'est un homme qui se sent
profondément humiliée et qui est en
train de conduire une guerre de
vengeance avec des moyens de destruction
terrible c'est un homme qui coupé du
monde c'est un on sait bien que depuis
de tout temps la russie a été dirigé à
cause de sa taille par des pouvoirs
extrêmement puissant tout pouvoir
extrêmement puissant a tendance à se
couper du monde monsieur poutine n'a pas
internet monsieur poutine ne n'a pas n'a
pas des messieurs poutine durant les
deux années du covin apave voyager en
dehors de la chine donc c'est un homme
qui a une perception des réalités
probablement assez assez fragile si vous
me permettez une citation c'est celle du
du patron du jer uc et le patron du
renseignement militaire situe le patron
de staline qui dit à la fin de la 2e à
la fin deuxième guerre mondiale après la
mort de staline il dit nous dise je
disais moins chef du renseignement à
staline ce qu'ils voulaient entendre
parce que je savais que tous mes
prédécesseurs avaient été fusillés pour
essayer de dire la vérité messieurs
générale ce soir est ce que vous nous
dites clairement sa langue de bois avec
la sincérité qu'elle aborde très dense
et que vous dites et les choses car
maladie mire poutine peut appuyer sur le
bouton nucléaire il peut évidemment le
faire à partir du moment où il l'a dit
où il a répété ou son mini affaires
étrangères l'a répété il faut placer
dans l'équation stratégique général que
nous ne pouvons pas penser qu'il ne le
fera pas il l'a dit il peut le faire il
peut faire à deux niveaux il peut le
faire au niveau stratégique si on en
venait à une enfant à un affrontement
direct entre la russie les forces de
l'otan il peut le faire aussi au niveau
tactique c'est à dire qu'il n'est pas il
est dans la doctrine russe de tirer des
armes nucléaires tactiques des petites
bombes nucléaires pour arriver à
débloquer des situations tactiques donc
il peut le faire bien sûr on va
poursuivre avez vous monsieur général
mais je voudrais faire réagir nos
chroniqueurs bruno pomart bruno est ce
que tu penses toi que poutine est
incontrôlable on rappelle que tu es
instructeur au raid que tu as une
expérience aussi de que sur le plan
militaire qu'est ce que tu en penses
comment tu sens les choses d'ailleurs
juste saluer permets moi de le faire
karim les dépôts les gendarmes du gign
qui ont fait l'évacuation de l'ambassade
de france et remis aux
autorités de pouvoir quitter le secteur
et de ceux de se promener d'aller sur
l'ouest du pays moi moi oui si l'accueil
n'est pas ce qu'on a fait a quand même
un malade mental c'est clair et net il
faut dire les choses comme elles sont on
n'est pas dans la diplomatie fait pas
diplomate au mans et je pense que
l'utilisation de la guerre pour poutine
et c'est un voeu qu'il souhaite depuis
bien longtemps pourquoi ce qu'il veut
réunir refaire le bloc russe qu'on a
connu les années la grande de russie
l'urss que j'ai connue parce que j'y
allais souvent et on peut craindre que
effectivement après la pérestroïka
puisqu'on a connu un démantèlement de
l'urss ils veulent à tout prix il le dit
le dit ouvertement la façon dont ils
attaquent ce pays qui était l'ukraine
nous pensent à dire que effectivement on
peut craindre le pire parce que rien ne
l'arrête macron s'époumoner et c'est
tout à son honneur 2 de défendre et
d'essayer de négocier avec lui le parler
avec lui pour éviter que ça dérape tout
mais quand on voit bruno tout ce qu'il
est capable de tout à moi je pense qu'il
est qu à laurence tu ne semble pas
partager ce connu non mais je c'est un
nom d'espérance quelque part parce que
évidemment je m'inquiète quand même en
fond très tout le monde mais je pense ce
serait complètement être ne pas
comprendre la situation que de ne pas
être inquiet mais effectivement il faut
quand même toujours essayé de se dire
qu'il y aura une sortie de crise ça
c'est sûr que de toute façon il ne sera
pas rapide je pense que tout le monde
l'a compris évidemment mais déjà
d'obtenir un cessez le feu à force de
diplômes acier c'est pour ça qu'il faut
absolument pas couper le contact ce
serait déjà une première étape
envisageable maintenant qu'il soit
capable de tout oui mais c'est aussi une
méthode pour semer la terreur parce que
le mot nucléaire c'est un mot qui
lorsqu'on est inclus concitoyens sèment
la terreur lorsque la centrale nucléaire
a été bombardée qui avait un incendie
même si ça n'a pas touché les réacteurs
pour tous ceux qui ont eu des alertes
dans la nuit et qui ont entendu que la
centrale nucléaire était en feu
effectivement ça sème la terreur quand
lui même évoque l'armé nucléaire ça sème
la terreur mais pour réussir à aller à
la fin de ce conflit effectivement comme
vous le disait comme vous le disiez
c'est du sang froid et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut à garder son sang-froid et
espérer une sortie mais d'abord un
cessez le feu mais personne ne pense que
les choses seront faciles d'accord
d'accord toi tu peins ce que y crée de
la surenchère pour créer de la peur mais
qu'il ne passera quand même pas à l'acte
s'est appuyé sur le bouton c'est pas bon
tu dis tu dis non portera sur un an bien
compris rendez vous compte de la
question non mais c'est clair la
question elle est très difficile elle
est très difficile à aborder c'est la
volonté de se dire qu'il ya une sortie
parce que si on abandonne cette idée ça
veut dire qu'on abandonne la diplomatie
ça veut dire qu'on abandonne les
négociations ça veut dire qu'on capitule
au froid ton nom est ce étonnant qu'ils
aient un peu plus de conviction qui est
aussi une certaine que celui de droite
c'est un nom parce que justement je
souscris pas à l'analyse que vient de
donner bruno mais qu'elle est à malices
de beaucoup de monde ici de considérer
que c'est un fou dangereux qui est parti
dans une forme de l'uby
incompréhensible en réalité je trouve
que dans son comportement il ya beaucoup
de choses qui vont pas dans ce sens là
notamment le fait qu'ils continuent en
fait à parler avec tout le monde à
négocier alors nous on voit en france on
met en scène les discussions avec
emmanuel macron mais en fait il parle
avec beaucoup de dirigeants dans le
monde et il est en fait dans une phase
je pense de négociations c'est-à-dire
celle inverse de ce que fait un fou vous
savez quand il ya une prise d'otages et
que quelqu'un se retranche avec des
enfants ou des otages dans un
appartement et qui finit par mettre par
se faire tuer c'est parce que justement
on peut plus négocier là en l'occurrence
il se passe exactement inverse il a
jamais autant négocier et de son point
de vue en position de force dorénavant
que aujourd'hui avec les dirigeants à
qui il parle en gros pour rebondir sur
ce qui a été dit sur la volonté de
refaire la grande russie on la comprend
et sait sont probablement son rêve j'ai
surtout l'impression qu'en fait c'est
quelqu'un qui s'est sentie à siéger à un
moment donné et que ce qui s'est passé
c'est que la halle alors j'avais
évidemment comme beaucoup de monde pas
du tout anticipé qui passerait à l'acte
et qui déclencherait une guerre en
revanche maintenant quinze jours plus
tard on a le sentiment qu'il a fait ça
parce que ils n'étaient pas écoutés pas
compris et est pas respectée en réalité
par notamment les américains mais pas
uniquement sur l'extension de l'otan et
la question de l'adhésion je sais
effectivement que selon toi si on en est
là 2 qu' il ya une responsabilité
majeure de la minière poutine mais tu
pense que nous aurions pu éviter la
situation dans laquelle on se trouve la
france est le seul responsable de la
guerre mais maintenant il ya une
situation qui est stable à la guerre qui
est la responsabilité de tout le monde
en fait alors avant de faire réagir de
que mes amis chroniqueur guillaume bigot
politologue essayiste n'est pas parce
que vous avez retenu guillaume à la fois
du général mais aussi on sent bien qu de
la créance de que de nos amis
chroniqueurs quelle est votre position à
vous quand vous analysez ça avec avec un
peu de recul si c'est possible il faut
essayer ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il ya un
déni le déni c'est un mécanisme très
très puissant en psychologie rossa et
des femmes qui sont trop simples jusqu'à
quasiment jusqu à terme elle dit non non
je ne suis pas enceinte et je pense que
le monde occidental un déni de la guerre
parce qu'on dit par exemple c'est la
première fois qu'à la guerre sur le
continent européen depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale c'est faux c'est faux la
guerre où il veut sa vie c'était
beaucoup plus proche sûr que l'ukraine
et veinules km2 - il ya eu 140 mille
morts
deuxième chose dit mais écoutez on
s'attendait pas à la guerre dans cette
région du monde depuis 2014 il ya eu 14
mille morts dans le conflit entre la
russie les soi disant petits hommes
verts qui n'ont rien à voir armées
russes en réalité l'armée russe
évidemment on a bien compris et les
troupes ukrainienne 14000 barre donc
c'est la poursuite de cette guerre par
d'autres moyens à une autre échelle une
certaine façon la russie n'a fait
qu'officialiser son intervention
militaire au donbass et généralisé
ailleurs condom bas cette intervention
c'est le premier point je pense qu'on a
un déni de la guerre pourquoi on a ce
délit de la guerre parce que quand vous
êtes puissant quand vous vivez dans un
monde qui vous ressemblent quand vous
avez netflix quand viennent les
supermarchés plein quand vous êtes les
rois du monde vous pensez que vos
valeurs sont dominantes dans le monde
vous ne voulez pas la guerre vous voulez
la paix et c'est une histoire éternelle
de l'humanité ceux qui veulent la guerre
sont ceux qui veulent renverser l'ordre
ou ceux qui en effet sont humiliés par
l'ordre établi premier point deuxième
point coûté la première guerre mondiale
avant la première guerre mondiale on a
dit c'est impossible qu'il y ait une
guerre tant les économies de la grande
bretagne l'allemagne sont intriqués
c'est un livre très célèbre norman un
goal 1911 fera jamais de guerre entre la
grande bretagne et l'allemagne les
millions de morts plus tard on aurait pu
s'attendre à ce que l'humanité se disent
bombe à cette fois ci on va sortir de ce
rêve les pacifistes sont des gens
extrêmement dangereux
bernadeaux sadi les optimistes ont pas
pitié des hommes il faut bien établir la
différence entre pacifique et passifs
historienne est impossible aujourd'hui
moi je suis pas du tout bien sûr moi je
suis pas du tout pacifiste je pense qu'à
des choses qui sont pire que la mort la
soumission est pire que la mort perdre
dans sa dignité vivre comme un esclave
c'est pire que la mort il faut être prêt
à faire la guerre mais évidemment il
faut considérer se rappeler que la
guerre c'est ce qui est pire donc il
faut tout donc est censé être pacifique
ces broutilles mais c'était
incontrôlable pour vous guérir ou pas
c'est une autre question mais justement
je voulais bien eu la seconde guerre
mondiale et voyez c'est je voudrais pas
qu on est soit obligé de rejouer temps
de remettre un jeton pour vérifier une
troisième fois que l'humanité ne sortira
pas de son état naturel c'est-à-dire
belliqueux on ne supprimera pas la
guerre personne alors il ya la question
de l'armé nucléaire qui est liée à la
psychologie de poutine moi je suis pas
psychologue j'ai pas d'informations sur
poutine je vois les informations je vois
que ce type n'a plus la même visage
qu'il ya ne serait-ce qu'un an ça laisse
à penser qu'il a des traitements
probablement des traitements là artisane
ça fait des années qu'on fantasme sur la
maladie de puccini mais il a changé
physiquement le président de la
république l'a dit il a constaté
lui-même on le voyons des 18 puisque les
images il ya quand on voit les gens
c'est différent deuxième chose il ya ces
protocoles dont on a entendu parler
c'est à dire que même dans son entourage
il y a pour lui une paranoïa locaux
vides alors pourquoi une paranoïa aucun
vide parce que vraisemblablement son
système immunitaire n'est pas le mien
est le vôtre c'est à dire que les effets
du vaccin ou les effets du co vite sur
quelqu'un qui a d une immunité très très
faible probablement c'est un péril de
mort donc si cette hypothèse est vrai ça
veut dire qu'il est probablement
physiquement très affaibli ensuite c'est
ce qui a été dit par le général
desportes est très vrai il ne vit pas
dans notre monde il n'a pas le même
rapport à la guerre à la paix il a pas
le même rapport à l'ordre qu'il
considère lui comme humiliant pour la
russie est dangereux pour la russie et
ainsi de suite mais il se peut également
qu'ils aient perdu un peu le contact
avec la réalité s'est rapidement 22
monde nous avons une part de
responsabilité nous européens et aussi
les américains dans ce qui se passe ou
pas du tout rapidement bien sûr la
culpabilité c'est poutine à 100% il a
commis une erreur d'appréciation massive
manifeste et il a fait quelque chose de
criminel eu égard au droit international
il est indéfendable
mais la responsabilité bien sûr la
responsabilité est partagée et
d'ailleurs il faut arrêter de tomber
dans ce manichéisme ce n'est pas les
gentils ukrainiens face aux méchants
russes la méchante autant face à la
gentille et russie ce sont deux
puissances qui se regardent en chiens de
faïence et si on comprend que les
polonais sont très inquiets par la
perspective d'être envahi par les russes
parce que c'est l'histoire qui veut ça
on peut tout à fait comprendre que les
russes soient très inquiets par la
perspective d'être attaqué par l'ouest
parce qu'ils ont été plus et c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est sûr millions
de morts n'oublierons jamais ce soir là
ce soir je veux que nous fassions de la
pédagogie et que nous tentions notre
objectif avec beaucoup d'humilité
effectivement le manichéisme est quelque
chose de simple mais il ne peut pas être
possible dans une guerre et face aux
enjeux et géopolitique ce général je me
retourne vers vous avant de me tourner
après vraiment verrou caillavet raquel
et vers yann qui n'ont pas parlé la
stratégie que nous adoptons dans cette
guerre qui oppose la russie à l'ukraine
est elle bonne le fait que nous ayons
décidé nous européens avaient les
américains les forces de l'otan de ne
pas intervenir militairement nous avons
eu raison c'est pas que nous n'avons
sait pas que nous ayons une raison c'est
que nous n'avons pas le choix c'est à
dire que si l'otan rentrent en contact
direct et c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas
fait de zone d'exclusion aérienne si on
a un affrontement direct entre deux
puissances nucléaires la logique c'est
comme ont progressivement aux extrêmes
donc il faut justement l'un arrivé à
contenir monsieur poutine sans arriver à
ahala au contact entre ces deux
puissances nous n'avons pas le choix et
le dance nous suivons donc dans
l'intérêt de l'ukraine parce que
l'ukraine serait totalement détruite par
ses bières dans notre intérêt à nous et
dans l'intérêt du monde dans l'intérêt
de tous ceux qui nous regardent il faut
absolument avons nous ne pouvons pas
faire donc à la stratégie que le
président de la république emmanuel
macron porte en maintenant le dialogue
même si on voit bien effectivement que
ça n'aboutit pas et en os fusée à
l'intervention militaire centrafricaine
des armes défensives qu'est ce que c'est
les armes défensives d'abord parce
qu'une arme est ce qu'elle ne peut être
que défensive il n'y a pas d'armes
défensives ou offensives une âme avait
pas défensive offensive par nature ll es
l et es les défensives ou offensives par
destination là on est bien dans une
agression sauvage de la part de monsieur
poutine est un peuple qui se défend donc
on va lui donner des armes capables
d'arrêter les deux grands dangers qui
sont les chars donc et on on leur envoie
massivement les chars les français
envoient par exemple des missiles milan
on envoie des armes anti char pour
arrêter les chars et dieu sait que ça
semble efficace et d'autre part on
envoie des missiles anti aériens qui
semble parfaitement efficace puisque on
a tous vu des avions décents du tiret
etc et ceux qui parce que ces armes
anti-aériennes existe monsieur poutine
ne peut pas délivrer toute la puissance
de destruction qu'il pourrait déployer
avec les 500 bombardier qui dispose il
ne peut pas le faire alors tout à
l'heure vous plus tout à l'heure il ya
un instant vous poser une question sur
foot il continue à dialoguer eh bien oui
évidemment on n'a jamais la mission a
l'impression qu'on est face à un mur non
mais c'est ce que c'est des fins de non
recevoir les déchets de boutines sadok
que le dialogue n'est possible que si
toutes mes exigences elle est de manquer
son entame de foule continue à perdre de
dialogue il faut que tu n'as pas mais on
n'a jamais tort
chercher jusqu'au bout a évité le pire
il faut maintenir le dialogue et ceux
qui connaissent un peu ces affaires là
on est un certain nombre autour du
plateau ça bien que dans toutes les
guerres on a eu en même temps la guerre
et la négociation à quoi sert la guerre
la guerre elle sert le plus souvent à
modifier les conditions de la négocier
avant la guerre monsieur poutine n'était
pas entendue alors il s'est lancé dans
cette affaire là pour faire pencher le
plateau danse à de la danse a dans son
sens là il continue la guerre pour
accroître là il est en train d'enterrer
kiev dans ses serres pour pouvoir
négocier c'est une grosse prise cave et
donc on négocie et ont pas pendant toute
la crise de cuba cris dans lequel le
monde aurait pu être détruit eh bien
monsieur khrouchtchev et monsieur le
quai des dix n'ont pas cessé par des
moyens un peu compliqué de parler et
c'est d'ailleurs après cette guerre à
cette crise de cuba est très jour
d'octobre 62 qui a été établi le
téléphone rouge de manière à ce que même
pendant les pires crises les chefs
puissent se parler